ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่
น้องเรียมสวัสดีครับนักเรียนว้าวอยากดู
กันมาแล้วเฮียตี้มาแล้วน้องเรียมมาฮ่าๆๆ
แล้ว
ครับมาม่าเจอกันในช่องคอมเปลี่ยนสัตว์เอา
ไทยโอเคค่ะมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับเรียมกับผู้
ภาษาไทยกันโอเคอ่าวันนี้วันนี้ม 5 เรียน
ภาษาไทยกันวันอะไรครับวันอะไร
วันศุกร์
วันนี้วาฬศุกร์วันศุกร์อาวันพฤหัสวัน
ศุกร์หน้านี่วันศุกร์แล้วเย้เย้วันศุกร์
คือสุวันศุกร์วันศุกร์ที่เท่าไหร่ครับวัน
นี้วันนี้ศุกร์ที่ 3
วันศุกร์ที่โอ้หนามวันศุกร์ที่ 3 วัน
ศุกร์ที่ 3 เดือนอะไรครับเดือน
ธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมปีคศอะไร
ครับคอ
ตต้าพันธุ์ 25  11
2554  11 ขอเคเคแล้วปีพตอะไรครับ
พ.ต.ต.
2564 ค่ะเออ
2564 โอเคมาเรียนภาษาไทยกันวันนี้อ้า
แล้ววันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันกี่โมง
แล้วครับ
ตอนนี้
17:15 น 5 โมง 15 นาทีใช่ไหม 5 โมงใช่ 5
ไงเป็นตอนข้อเท้าหรือตอนเย็นครับเป็นตอน
เย็นค่ะขอเป็นตอนเย็นโอเคฮะและอาทิตย์
กำลังตก
ดินแล้วนะค่อนนี้
พระอาทิตย์บ๊ายบาย
บ๊ายบายอย่าพระอาทิตย์ตกแล้วโอเคอ้าววัน
นี้วันนี้วันนี้เราอ่ามีเรื่องอะไรมาคุย
กันครับวันนี้
วันนี้เราจะคุยกันเรื่อง
ครอบครัว
เรื่องครอบครัวเข้
ครอบครัวนี้เธอได้อยู่ที่ไหนครับเนี่ย
อ้าครอบครัวป่าอยู่ใน
สวนสาธารณะนะหัวหน้าเป็นสวนสาธารณะหมอเอ้
ในสวนในสวนสาธารณะมีอะไรบ้างครับ
โหมีต้นไม้
5 ต้นไม้อ๋อนี่ใช่ไหมครับมีต้นไม้ต้นไม้
นี่ต้นไม้ว้าวมีต้นไม้เยอะเลยให้คะนี่
สนามหญ้า
น้ำยาอันนี้นี้เป็นสนามหญ้าหน้ามีหญ้านี้
เป็นหญ้ามีญาติเยอะเป็นสนามยากนิดสนาม
หญ้ามีต้นไม้ a แล้วมีอะไรอีกในสวน
สาธารณะครับมีมานั่ง
ม้านั่ง
มีม้านั่งเหรอครับมานั่งตัวไหนครับ
เต็มที่หมา
เรียงเรียกหมานั่งอ๋อ
คนไทยเรียกหมานั่งเหมือนกันตัวนี้ครับอ่า
ม้านางหน้าเป็นหมานั่งไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่หมาแบบ
นี้ใช่ไหมครับ
ไปตาย
ห่าที่เป็นหมานั่งเอาโอเคโอเค
ห้างไม้ก็มีนาง
มีดอกมาก
อีดอกไม้ในส่วนด้วยแล้วนะอ้านี่ดอกไม้อ่ะ
มีดอกไม้ในสวนโอเคแค่นี้ค่ะไม้สนามยากมา
นั่งดอกไม้
ในสวนเอา k  k  OK
555 แล้วก็เมื่อกี้น้องเรียมบอกว่า
ครอบครัว
ครอบครัวครอบครัวมาที่สวนสาธารณะใช่ไหม
ครับแล้วอะไรคั่วนี้ครอบครัวนี้มีกี่คน
ครับ
หมอครอบครัวนี้
มี 3 คน
ถ้ามี 3 คนอ่ะเองแล้วสามคนนี้มีใครบ้าง
ครับ
มีพ่อ
หามีพ่อโอเคพ่อคนนี้คนนี้เป็นพ่อใช่ไหม
น้อเป็นข้อพ่อเป็นผู้ชายใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะ
เป็นผู้ชายโอเค
น้าน
นี้ก็เป็นไงน้อเค
อายอ้าครอบครัวนี้มีพ่อแล้วมีใครอีกครับ
มีลูกสาวลูกสาวว่านี่ลูกสาว
ลูกสาวลูกสาวเป็นผู้หญิงใช่ไหมลูกสาวอา
สาวเป็นผู้หญิง 5
ครอบครัวนี้มีพ่อมีลูกสาวแล้วมีพระเอก
ครับคนนี้เป็นวันนี้เป็นอะไรครับลูกชาย
มีพ่อมีลูกสาวมีลูกชายอ่า
ครอบครัวนี้มี 3 คนอ้าโอเคแล้วเอเซียตี
เห็นคุณพ่อคุณพ่อกำลังทำอะไรครับหลวงพ่อ
กำลังทำอะไรพ่อชี้อาฉี
เอ่อ 5 ก็
บอกลูกสาวอ้าวบอกลูกสาวตายก็ลูกชายให้
อ้าไปนั่งนั่งนั่งที่ไหนครับ
นั่งบ่นมานั่งอ๋อโอเคอ่าไปไปนั่งบนม้า
นั่งครับมาโอเค
หน้าบอกลูกสาวกับลูกชายไปนั่งบนม้านั่ง
หน้านี่ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ลูกสาวกับลูกชายนั่ง
บนมานั่งแล้ว
ใช่ครับ
5  and แล้วคุณพ่อคุณพ่อทำอะไรครับหน้า
เมื่อกี้นี่พี่อ่ะพี่เห็นคุณพ่อถือเผื่อ
นี้อันนี้เรียกอะไรครับกล้อง
อ๋อเป็นจุดถ่ายรูป RO กล้องแอบถ่ายรูป
โอเค
5 นี่คุณพ่อกำลังกำลังเขาลูก
ถ่ายรูปลูกสาวถ่ายรูปลูกชายนั่งหน้าบนมา
นั่งว้าวโอเคอา
น้องเรียมเคยถ่ายรูปไหมครับ
เตรียมชอบถ่ายรูปค่ะ
ชอบถ่ายรูป K นะชอบถ่ายรูปไหมค่ะอย่าตี
God ชอบถ่ายรูปนิดหน่อยชอบนิดหน่อย
ให้เขาเรียนชอบมากๆอ๋ออ๋อชอบมากๆถ่ายรูป
มากเลยใช่ไหมครับชอบมากถ่ายมากไงรอบนิด
หน่อยถ่ายนิดหน่อยถ่ายนิดหน่อย 555
ตั้งเวลาเวลาถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูปถ้าเราถูกไล่
อยู่ใกล้ๆ
ง่ายๆอายุใกล้รูปใหญ่ใช่ไหมรูปใหญ่
เนื้อ
ถ้าเราอยู่อยากได้รูป
รอบๆแบบนี้หรือว่าง่ายใช่เราต้องอยู่
ไกลใช่ไหมใช่อยู่ปลายอ่ะตอนนี้คุณพ่อก็
อยากได้รูปขว้าง 5 ออกก็ต้องเป็นไงครับ
เดินถอยหลัง
ๆๆคุณคอก็ถอยมา
ถอยถอยถอยๆอาคอยไปไกลๆนะโอเคอาจจะได้มี
รูปกว้างๆใช่ไหมอ่าแค่นี้ถอยถอยไปคุณพ่อ
มองข้างหลังไหมครับ
พ่อไม่ได้มองข้างลายได้มองหน้าไม่ได้มอง
เพราะมองมองกล้องใช่ไหมครับของกล้องมอง
ด้านนาถอยถอยถอยถอยๆถอยมาชายถอยมาแล้ว
เป็นยังไงบ้างครับ
ว่า
ถอยมาชนกับอะไรครับตรงนี้ชนต้องรู้ว่า
ตรงนี้มีรั้วอยู่ใช่ไหมครับพรุ่งนี้
โอนอยู่ว่าอ๊อดรู้ว่า 5 มีรั้วรั้วดอกไม้
ใช่ไหมชนแล้วคุณพ่อเป็นไงครับตอนนี้ล้ม
จะล้มลงไปสายว้าวล้มไปท้อถอยหลังล้มลงไป
หาเราก็ต้องล่ะคะกล้อง
ลองก็ตกลงมาตกลงมาเลยอ่าใช่ก็อกคุณเพาะ
ล้มแล้วต้องก็ตกลงไปเออ
เรียงเห็นครับลูกสาว
ลูกสาวพี่สาว
ลูกสาวลูกชาย
ใจหน้าตกทรายโอ้ยพ่อ
ลูกสาวตกใจนะฮะ
ใจวิ่งมาวิ่งมาดูคุณพ่อ
แล้ว 5 คุณพ่อเป็นไงครับคุณพ่ออิล้มรถ
อยู่ถ้าลง
อารมณ์ลงไปนอนอยู่เนาะคอน
นอนอยู่ตอนไม้ดอกไม้คนช่อง
ดอกไม้เลยอ่ะ
แล้วครับ
ลูกสาว
กับลูกชายก็วิ่งอ้าวิ่งมาวิ่งมาดูวิ่งมา
ดูคุณพ่อใช่ไหม
วิ่งมาดูคุณพ่อ
แล้วลูกสาว
สาวทำอะไรครับก็หยิบอ้าหยิบก็เมื่อกี้อา
หยิบกล้องขึ้นมาถ่าย
รูป
ถ่ายรูปชายถ่ายรูปคุณพ่อ
ว้าว 5 แล้วลูกสาวผู้ถ่ายรูปคุณพ่อแล้ว
เป็นยังไงครับนิที่ 5 นี่คือรูปของคุณพ่อ
ที่ล้มลงไปอยู่ในดอกไม้ใช่ไหมครับ
เครียดนี้ค่ะดอกไม้อันนี้เรียกดอกอะไรคะ
5 ดอกไม้เมื่อตีคิดว่าดอกไม้นี้น่าจะ
เป็นดอกทิวลิปใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะ
ดอกทีวีคิดว่าดอกทิวลิป
ใช้ครับดอกทิวลิปใช่ไหมที่วาดดอกทิวลิป
เหมือนมั้ยเนี่ย
พอได้อยู่นะอ้าอันนี้แหละนี่นี้ดอกทิวลิป
นะมีดอกทิวลิปเยอะแยะเลยให้ค่ะดอกที่มี
แดงห้าสีแดงอะ
มี
สียอกซ่อมอู่สีทรง
สีส้มสีเหลือง
ๆ
นี่ดอกทิวลิปมีหลายสีพี่อาร์ตี้เคยเห็น
ดอกทิวลิปสีชมพูด้วยสีชมพูมีมีดอกทิวลิป
สีขาว
ใช่ค่ะห้าสีขาวสวยเพื่อที่ชอบดอกทิวลิปสี
ขาวอ่านี่เชอรี่ระบายสีระบายสีให้ดอก 10
สีขาวโอ้โห
ไม่เหมือนดอกทิวลิปเลยเออโอเคอ๋อดอก
ทิวลิปครับหน้ามีดอกทิวลิป
โอ้
โห้
แล้วก็ได้รูปรูปภาพๆได้อ้อนอนอยู่ในดอก
ทิวลิป 1 ใบอ่าใช่กับเราเรียกว่ารูปถ่าย
ได้ครับเรียกว่ารูปถ่ายค่ะนี่คือรูปถ่าย
รูปถ่ายไม่มีมือ
มือจับรูปถ่ายอ๋อใช่ครับนี่มือมือถือ
คู่หูรูปหรือรูปชายเรียมหู
ปากกาปากาหน้าเพื่อตีก็ถือปากกา
อาอันนี้นี่ก็ถือถือถือรูปถ่ายรูปถ่าย
นายครับฮ่าๆๆถ้าเราใช้มือถือ 5 ถือนะอ่า
นี้คือกล้องเหมือนกันถือกล้องถึง
5 ทรายครับ
หาน้องเรียมก็เคยไปเที่ยวสวนสาธารณะ
ไปเที่ยวสวนสาธารณะกับครอบครัวไหมครับ
เรียม
คิดว่า
เคยเลยอ๋อโอเคเคยอ่ะแล้วเวลาไปสวนสาธารณะ
กับครอบครัวไปกี่คนครับ
โหไปหลายคน
ไปหลายคนว้าวในครอบครัวของน้องเรียมที่ไป
สวนสาธารณะ 5 มีใครไปบ้างครับ
งูครอบครัวของเบียร์ม.คอาไหล่มาก
มีคนเยอะมากๆ
ได้คะมีพ่อ
พ่อพ่อพ่อเข้าค่ายอ่ะเยี่ยมมีแม่
มีอ้อมีแม่ไปด้วยนะนี่แม่ไป
มีเรียม
หน้านี้เป็นเรียม
มีที่สาว
รีย์คะมีพี่สาวโอเคมีแม่มีพี่สาว
มีเรียงมีพ่อแม่พี่สาวอาบแล้วมีเตรียมมี
น้องชายไหม
ไม่มีค่ะไม่มีหรอไม่มีอ่าในครอบครัวน้อง
เรียนมีพ่อมีแม่มีแม่มีพี่สาวแล้วก็มี
เรียหมอครอบครัวน้องเรียมมี
4 คนใช่ไหม 4 คน
แล้วพี่อาร์ตี้เทียบที่ไปสวนสาธารณะในค่ะ
ไปครับเปียตี้ไปสวนสาธารณะแต่เพียงตี้ไป
สวนสาธารณะมีเพศที่มีลูกชายมีเพศที่เป็น
พ่ออ่านแล้วก็มีแม่อ้ามีแม่แล้วก็มีเรียก
ที่ไม่มีไม่มีลูกสาวไม่มีลูกสาวแต่มีลูก
ชายได้งับมีลูกชาย
2 คนน่ะที่เปลี่ยนเป็นสีแดงนักเรียนจะ
ได้เห็นชัดๆนะครับสีแดงอะมีลูกชาย
สองคนอะลูกชายมี 2 คนแล้วมีเพียงตี้แล้ว
ก็มีแม่อ่า
ถ้ารวมเป็น 4 คนเหมือนกันหน้า 4
แต่ไม่มีไม่มีลูกสาว
ง่า
าาน้องเรียมมีลูกสาวแต่ไม่มีสิลูกชายได้
มั้ยไม่มีผู้ชายครอบครัวของน้องเรียมไม่
มีลูกชายไม่มีครับเพียงกับพี่สาวของเรียม
2 คนเฮียตี้มีลูกชายไม่มีที่มีลูกสาว
เทียบผิดชอบไปสวนสาธารณะใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ
ชอบไปสวนสาธารณะเราไปสวนสาธารณะก็จะถ่าย
รูปแบบนี้เลยถ่ายรูปที่สวนสาธารณะกัน
อาหารเหินชอบไปดู
อะไรคะ
หน้าที่สวนสาธารณะก็จะไปดูต้นไม้ดูนกดูมี
บึงอ่ะปกติที่สวนสาธารณะจะมีบึงน้ำ
หมอหาใช้ครับมีบึงน้ำบึงนางบัว
มีบึงน้ำมีปลาอยู่ในพึ่ง 3 ด้วยนะลำบาก
แล้วเฮีย tekela วาดปากและ
ปลา
หาใจกับมีปลา
ลงไปว่ายน้ำไม่ให้ลง by
ดูถ่ายรูปจ้าได้อาหารอยู่อ้าแล้วนักเรียน
แล้วครับนักเรียนนักเรียนไปสวนสาธารณะไป
ทำอะไรที่สวนสาธารณะกันบ้างครับน้าขี้
คอมเม้นท์บอกบอกเครียดอี้บอกน้องเรียม
หน่อยไปไปทำอะไรที่สวนสาธารณะการครับใช่
ค่ะ
เรียงชอบไปเดินเล่น 5 อ๋อไปเดินเล่นที่
สวนสัตว์สนะเรียงชอบไปปั่นจักรยานพ่อปั่น
จักรยานโอเค
ใช่อ๋อ
จักรยาน
ปั่นจักรยานหาว้าวถ้ามี
พิมพ์มาบอกพี่อาร์ตี้กับเตรียมนะคะๆครับ
อาจจะได้รู้นะครับโอเคอ้าถ้างั้นวันนี้
อ่ะหมดเวลาอีกแล้วหมดเวลาแล้วเวลาเหรอ
งั้นเดี๋ยวเราก็มาเจอกันใหม่คราวหน้าหน้า
กลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกันนะครับฮะโอเควันนี้
เพื่อตีกับน้องเรียมก็ลาไปก่อนครับอ่ามา
ให้สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้งามซอยคำนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เจอกันใหม่เจอกันใหม่บ๊ายบาย